were invited to this weekend's Chinese
New Year celebrations with the Asian
American Pacific Islander Chamber of
Commerce and backed us a live look here
at the Bellagio right sure yeah that's
in the conservatory there they're all
decked out for the Chinese New Year well
the party we're talking about it's over
at the Chinatown Plaza and that's where
we find Candace Charles this morning
good morning Candace we're talking
Dancing Dragons and fan dances and great
food tell us the meaning behind the
holiday for some people who don't know
too much about it
good morning YouTube good morning folks
yes dancing is definitely top of Mind as
I have two wonderful dances here from
the happy face dance studio you guys can
get to see this weekend lots to do and
see here and it's all brought to you by
aopi Chamber of Commerce I have their
Shannon Yang with me now tell us a
little bit about the meaning behind the
holiday
um so Chinese holiday is the biggest
holiday in the entire year
um we enjoy food we enjoy family reunion
everything that you can think about
amazing okay so what can people enjoy
for the two-day Festival so this year we
brought you with a lot of food different
cultural performances and these amazing
dances of course and the traditional
lion dance yeah correct and the ruffle
jarring we have gifts to give away we
have red envelopes for the kids we have
mascots running around all the time for
you to take pictures we have Instagram
check in spots with all the photo ops
anyways like a lot of different things
going on and not to mention we have
really amazing food vendors yes yes we
were with extra sweet treat a little bit
earlier a lot of Foodies here yes and we
also got to try a little bit of number
one boba tea yeah number one boba tea
extra sweet we have wagu beef slider
from like chubby cattle but that's only
a sneak preview so definitely come and
check it out yes you gotta see it for
yourself and it's actually also
Vietnamese New Year on Sunday as well so
I have the one and only Queen pamphon
thank you so much for joining us and her
daughter here they'll be doing a fashion
show tell us a little bit about what you
guys are wearing well I'm wearing the
queen dress the Vietnamese cream dress
and also is wearing the traditional oh
yeah oh beautiful we're celebrating the
Year of the Cat absolutely yes
Vietnamese New Year as well as the Year
of the Cat I lot to see and do down here
you guys thank you so much for joining
us all again it kicks off tomorrow 11
today that's Saturday on Sunday from 1
to 8 left to see and do and from all of
us here let's stay really quickly
[Music]
happy New Year you guys
oh that is just fantastic Candace thank
you so much and those little girls
behind her that was adorable bill in the
show yeah don't forget Downtown
Summerlin is bringing back its Lunar New
Year parade on Sunday it's at 5 p.m and
you'll see a host of dancers stilt
Walkers and dragon Downtown Summerlin
celebrating you're the rabbit from the
23rd through the 27th with lots of
special decorations so hold off the wind
Sherry no wind what looks like